so let's apply that on a macro level you
have the left today with generation Z
and what do they want to do they want to
ban Halloween costumes for being
offensive they want a ban video games
they want to ban merry Christmas and
Christmas displays and they actually hey
this is the true story we have an
overlay if you want to breed an entire
generation of conservatives ok leftist
ban Halloween candy which they are so I
want to talk about Generation Z and the
2020 election when I started doing this
ok yes we do have them every four years
one of every four years let me go to my
Apple calendar Wow let me grab my chair
for this [ __ ]
[Applause]
I love the chairs so there's nothing
creepier than a man dressed as the Joker
yelling chair
like if that were in if that were in a
piece of literary fiction that would be
foreshadowing - guaranteed clown rape oh
yes what keep the genius well Jared
Leto's an ass I don't understand what
you're saying
and I don't like it people I'm actually
terrified of clowns he's right in the
front rows make me uncomfortable and
he's right next to a hot dog who cheered
for my nipples so so Andrew Breitbart he
famously said that politics are
downstream of culture and I will say
this it proved I think more true than
ever in 2016 when President Trump upset
the establishment both on the left and
the right because he really was the
first sort of cultural candidate that we
had ever seen and that's why he wanted
that's why a lot of people supported him
right yeah okay I think I mean if you
look at what Donald Trump did and you
know listen I'm very straightforward
about this in the primaries he wasn't my
number one pick I think there a lot of
people were cautiously optimistic I've
been pretty been pretty damn happy and
also wildly entertained since he's
president
he not only pissed off Democrats he not
only pissed off Republicans I mean he
changed the way that polling data is
gathered at this point no one can trust
it he changed the way that presidents
communicate with the public and that's
all because of culture that's because of
new media that's because he's a cultural
icon and now you have the media
industrial complex that's my term but I
want you guys to go forward and use it
because every time you have some Bernie
guy the military-industrial complex say
media entertainment industrial complex
and watch their head explode and then
I'll take 90% of your paycheck but I
want you to know this also includes we
used to think of media as traditional
media cable television right but now
more than ever it includes big tech and
big tech has spent the entire first term
attempting to reverse what they see is a
disaster what they see is their moral
imperative is to fight Donald Trump and
in case you think I'm making stuff you
know anyone who watches our show knows
that we list sources and I try not to
make an argument for someone I disagree
with
if I can let them make their argument
for themselves so lest you have
forgotten let's take a quick trip down
memory lane to Google's internal meeting
after the election can we go to that
that no this is probably not the most
joyous TGIF we have had and you know
space if most people here are pretty
upset and pretty sad for because of the
election I certainly find a petition
crack deeply offensive and I know many
of you do too
back a very sad short text that read
people are leaving staff is crying we're
gonna lose for the first moment I really
felt like we were gonna lose kick in the
gut that we were gonna lose and it was
really meaningful for the u.s.
immigration system didn't go exactly how
I wanted that any immediate changes
after January's inauguration of the new
administration highly unlikely but we
are course will keep a close watch on
this our policy office in in DC is all
over it and we will keep you informed
but we will keep Googlers interests at
heart
okay what point you get a haircut you
have a national meeting the first guy
who looks like a hobo and the second
lady who just I guess she's been crying
all day anyway I got him but someone get
him in check so here's the deal if 2016
was the world war one of culture wars as
the term has been coined 2020 is going
to be the world war two and more
importantly I want to talk about this in
2020 more important than ever is going
to be you generation Z and I think yeah
I actually applaud you guys and I'll
tell you why
it's super important because the exact
same establishment and we use this term
what I'm talking about is the media
entertainment industrial complex so
people say well what do you mean when
you say establishment what I'm talking
about the media here and their targeting
of generation Z I'm talking about
ABC NBC CBS CNN MSNBC everything not
named Fox News every band you listen to
every single Hollywood junket and
conference every single company people
want to talk about big money in politics
go look at the biggest companies in the
world one through five are all big tech
companies who overwhelmingly support
liberal candidates and directly the DNC
platform these are steps so if I made it
clear what the establishment is I want
to make sure that we're not in murky
territory because I don't want [ __ ] we
go to be like because other people throw
out establishment go what do you mean no
no people don't like piss off so that's
the establishment they're targeting you
generation Z specifically and let me
tell you why that's because Generation Z
which is you know the next generation
below Millennials some people are like
what Z it sounds like a hip-hop group no
it's not they're not opening up soon I
said Kris Kross because I'm a millennial
so that's a reference I still understand
one guy Chi is good from a chair so
Generation Z you guys need to know this
is the most conservative generation to
have come along in decades okay
[Applause]
this is not a doom and gloom scenario
here I know we get that a lot on cable
news from both the left on the right and
it gets clicks but like Linus with his
little blankie I bring you tidings of
great joy
you guys are incredibly conservative but
the media the establishment wants to
engineer all of you into thinking
otherwise and boomers I want you to be
listening because a lot of you think
that the culture war is lost a lot I
think this country's going to hell in a
handbasket it couldn't be further from
the truth if you go to CNN and Teen
Vogue because that's still a thing I
guess they're Teen Vogue they want you
to believe that Generation Z is the most
progressive generation of all time right
these are articles that have actually
been published it could not be further
from the truth let me make my case here
and the phenomenon by the way is global
so let's go to the UK I want to make
sure have my stats right here because we
actually care about that a recent UK
study I know that's sort of implying
this a surprising don't who might that
be I don't know people who done deny the
Armenian Genocide I'm just hinting I
don't know I don't know what you're
saying but actually it no please this is
just like my greatest hits of awful my
mom is so ashamed she had to glue this
patchy beard I'm just like why can't you
be like mom because I suck I'm terrible
the Joker and the hot dog nipple guy is
more well off than I am
so one make sure I get the stat right
this is global in the UK where a lot of
Americans don't even believe there are
true conservatives I mean we understand
brexit but the idea of sort of
conservative in comparison the United
States there was a recent study 59% of
generation Z respondents said that their
views were moderate or conservative now
compare that with 83 percent of
Millennials and 85 percent of Generation
X or Gen Xers who identified as quite or
very liberal I think we have that
overlay there from Forbes and Business
Insider do you guys get that I can't see
the overlays from where I am so here's
what's even more interesting though
right because you go well 59% identify
as moderate or conservative that doesn't
mean a whole lot let's dive a little bit
deeper especially into their party
affiliation in the United States from
2008 to 2016 generation Z Republicans
increased by one percent that doesn't
seem like much okay stay with me here
independence increased by about 6
percent that doesn't seem like much
here's the kicker here's the cold water
I hope you have your mouth guard on like
I was talking about earlier a reference
that I don't fully understand but I
heard the Ultimate Warrior's saying once
I thought it was cool
Democrats decreased with generation Z by
8%
and I know there's some leftist watching
right now right no okay
remember baby boomers okay who are known
for their support of Trump right the
boomer generation they're often referred
to derogatorily by oh they're left it's
like boomers listen you know what thank
you boomers for our country and for
electing our president I'm grateful to
you I see a few of you in the audience I
can I can only spot you by the
reflection off your chrome domes but
that's okay you just saw my nipples so
it's an even trade
we both have dirt in each other remember
baby boomers who are now known right
they're known as conservatives right you
brought your parents probably baby
boomers we think of them as one of those
conservative generations they were the
most liberal far-left generation you
could imagine when they were younger
right 1979 to 28 to 39 year old
demographic they identified 45% Democrat
only 19% Republican these were the
people who were out there smoking pot
and putting daisies and [ __ ] cops
rifles okay
so the point that I make here is that
boomers were far more liberal okay far
more left than Generation Z is today if
you go to boomers back when they're in
their 20s or the 30s they were much more
liberal than Generation Z is today and
here's just thing that's important you
need to understand this
that doesn't change right so 59% in the
UK are identifying there's conservative
or moderate the chances of that 59%
shrinking as they grow up as they pay
bills as they get a job as they have
children statistically is almost
impossible the likelihood is that they
become more conservative that that 59
percent goes to 60 70 50 I went back to
59 and I want to explain this how many
people here are our Millennials as
opposed to generations okay so this is
this is something I think a lot of
people miss right Millennials we grew up
in the era of george w bush right and at
that point there was there was Green Day
and there were sort of Christian
conservative was the establishment
people wanted to rebel and I rock
against bush and no effects and shitty
punk music and badder living skater boy
and we hate our parents and they're all
conservative right because Americans are
counterculture a list by by design only
unlike Canada where I was raised right
who bent over and kissed the ring of the
royalty America flip stop what are you
Diamondback rattles
I mentioned Canada they just it's not
really distracting it's a little gay I'm
just letting you know
[Laughter]
not unlike my home country of Canada you
just walk down the streets of Montreal
it's a bunch of people going that's why
they're doing and Johnny friendly it's
just them so Americans are a
counterculture by design right now
that's what we grew up with as
Millennials but let's look at Generation
Z they grew up many of you you grew up
in the most lopsided authoritarian
leftist American America ever okay think
about this not only when generation Z
grew up we didn't have it in have George
Bush a lot of these people they don't
remember right Colton nearly all them
they wouldn't remember now 11
not only did left us have the White
House right for two years from away two
to ten not only they have the White
House not only do they have the Senate
not only do they have the House of
Representatives but they had the entire
media the entire entertainment industry
does anyone here remember when Barack
Obama won there was that video where
they were pledging allegiance to be of
service to Barack Obama round of
applause I don't remember that it was
like Demi Moore and Ashton Kutcher and
the Red Hot Chili Peppers pledging
allegiance to a president how symporter
people well we're at very important how
dare you sir I can't here we have this
feedback going on but you know I'm sure
it was very clever it wasn't super cheap
sorry I feel bad now but I don't I
shouldn't feel that but they were
pledging allegiance to a man Barack
Obama yeah I remember Ashton anyone
remembered who else opposed to me more
Ashton Kutcher right out Chili Peppers
that guy from The Avengers a bunch of I
don't know but here's the thing that was
the backboard right any kind of
rebellion any kind of counterculture
it's rebelling against something so you
have a backboard and when we were young
you had George W Bush and you had sort
of the conservative establishment and
Dick Cheney that's how they saw it these
kids had Barack Obama they had Nancy
Pelosi they had pledging allegiance to
Barack Obama they had far left
everything and I'm not only that so you
combine that with this sort of natural
anti-authoritarian just having a problem
with general you know that the
mainstream culture but leftists okay
suck they really do they suck
[Applause]
they say I wasn't saying they said you
shouldn't have cheered for that now
you're gonna feel very ashamed I was
saying they suck the fun out of
everything yes yes come on they turned
chairs into love sacks at the mall
cheering love sacks
people love couple of sacks man can I I
want to tell you a personal story okay
is it true story I don't tell stories
that aren't true sometimes I do but this
is true so when I was a kid I one of my
best friends we were going to this
sledding hill in Montreal or at South
Shores called plastic Lomond oh okay he
would just go it was wildly unsafe there
was no chairlift there was a place where
some people you could see some
footprints in a trail of blood from
where all the children had fallen before
you we had something called a GT snow
racer which if you don't remember it
looked like a jet ski you would ride in
the snow but it just immediately wracked
your testicles and you regretted all of
your decisions so anyway it was a
sweating place and I was in the car with
my friend my best friend at the time and
his dad was in the car and I remember
his dad stopping and asking for
directions we got lost and he asked this
woman and she said yeah you know go left
and there you gonna go to Brighton
you're gonna go down long ago and it
turned my friend he's made it I was 11
years old and I said well that's it
we're never gonna get the plus plum on
no now he was why Steven I said because
your dad asked a woman for directions
right it's not that funny this is a true
story and then he goes but he thought it
was hysterical okay he thought it was
hysterical as Joker thinks murder is
here or hot dog with my nipples so he's
laughing and he laughs he goes hey dad
dad dad
did you hear what Steven just said he
says no he says Steven just said that
you will never find PLAs plum on Dom
because you asked a woman for directions
and his dad tilted because II was in the
front seat tilted the mirror back aiming
it at me so I just see his eyes and his
stupid oh and his stupid little Bruce
Springsteen looking dead this doesn't
matter to you but to me I'm revisiting
this
I'm just opening old wounds and he looks
in the mirror and he's looking back at
me he goes uh that comment is incredibly
offensive and I won't tolerate that kind
of sexism ever again in this car and I
said I seriously I'm sorry
I don't want to but I said and of course
a call went to my parents I was wrong to
say that last part but think about that
for a second that was my that was my
first experience as a kid with a parent
who didn't have a sense of humor who
couldn't stand fun I mean I have done so
much worse than that that was what got
me in trouble
now let's imagine I never wanted to go
to his house again okay that's the point
I never wanted to go to that kids house
again I was like that kid's dad I want
nothing to do with him so let's apply
that on a macro level you have the left
today with generation Z and what do they
want to do they want to ban Halloween
costumes for being offensive they want
to ban video games they want to ban
merry Christmas and Christmas displays
and they actually hey this is the true
story we have no really if you want to
breed an entire generation of
conservatives okay leftist ban Halloween
candy which they are they want to ban
Halloween candy and if you read that
okay rattlesnakes and if you read that
article these people are talking about
HuffPo and this person well we actually
have had great success we give out
playing cards they're made of paper and
recyclable gum oh that sounds like the
party of your neighborhood so what does
that do
that creates a rejection and we already
have a generation who is wildly
conservative Generation Z do you think
that banning Halloween candy in the name
of saving the earth because aoc created
a five-page bill that I doubt she could
even read it's going to win more
conservatives or less and here's
something else - Generation Z is super
conservative in spite of all of their
surroundings in spite of all of your
surroundings grade school teachers only
27% are Republicans right if you go to
college professors that number drops to
9% and about I talked about this last
year roughly
40% of colleges have no conservative
professors at all think about do you
think that you could find 40% of
colleges with with zero black professors
okay do you think you can find any
college with zero black professors okay
how about any college with zero lesbian
professors how about any college with 0
black lesbian professors so we have more
colleges with black lesbian professors
than conservative professors and you
want to tell me that you give a rat's
ass about diversity and despite being
brainwashed overwhelmingly by the
Democratic establishment right by
teachers professors from grade school
all the way through college generations
he's inspiring to me because listen I'm
a millennial most of my generation sucks
okay yes this is we're worse than
hotdogs nipple guy we're not so I look
at Generation Z I say hey you've got to
figure it out you play a little too much
call of duty I don't know what this
whole Mountain Dew game fuel thing is
but you know I mean you take the win
where you can get it so and this is why
this is important it ties into big tech
okay generation Z is resisting to the
left is American education in the media
well here's here's a reason why more and
more of you are getting your news from
non-traditional outlets right by round
of applause how many young people here
have cable oh wow that was surprising
not quite the the uproar as I would hear
for chairs but yeah
[Applause]
cable and chair somewhere brian Stelter
is going i'm totally straight we get it
but here's the thing big tech they saw
how dangerous right that this was that
their power was in 2016 and so because
most of you get your news from
non-traditional outlets they've now
taken measures to throttle to shadow ban
and blacklist conservative content how
many people here have been following
that right you guys know about it what's
so bizarre
as I mentioned brie Larson you hiss me I
mentioned big tech throttling and
blacklist and conservative Condor like
yeah we don't have a crowd animator like
Lilly Singh
I meant they killed their selves I
killed themselves because it's unfunny
okay it's not as bad as you think it is
get your mind out of the gutter so big
the big tech giants they want to censor
or curate and I know people want to
support censor because we're not talking
about the government but a culture of
censorship okay so hang me on these
words why because they said the story
they showed you was that they're
concerned about radicalism right who
else he remembers the infamous New York
Times article and a study that was
published everywhere claiming that
conservative and all light content led
to radicalization of the youth on
YouTube it was a Casper the Friendly
Ghost if she were cute but if I were a
single young person I would want to date
you just based on that boo it sounded
like Neil Patrick Harris in the matrix
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway that was a famous study you guys
remember to say that I questioned the
methodology of a study that listed
philip defranco as a representative of
the alt-right would be an understatement
here's the thing though there is a new
more recent study that actually shows
conservative content the kind of content
that you watch d radicalizes young
people and this doesn't cut this
shouldn't come as a surprise to anyone
who actually watches our content or
like-minded content we are the only
content creators who consistently
regularly advocate against violence who
encourage open dialogues and we
encourage the rationalization of our own
opinions right we've always prioritize
we've tried to we've tried to we've
always tried to prioritize critical
thinking evidence-based think proper
proper sourcing and yes yes dick jokes
we do that as we dare you Swedish start
what about my fill of her can you
imagine when she turns 18 nightmare
okay don't criticize her because she's
sixteen and thrust herself in front of
the political spotlight I get it
she's like I don't know the worst I'll
say about about Greta and I I won't say
anything it's the worst I'll say about
really she's she's the kind of kid he'd
be like I've got your nose no you
haven't
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's it if I get bangs you that you
guys were witnesses it didn't go any
further than that
and Vox well he was banned because he
said that she didn't have a sense of
humor about the got your nose joke so
here's the big tech was never concerned
about radicalization all right I want to
make that really clear here they're just
concerned they're terrified of what you
Generation Z are already becoming and so
they threw out this idea that you're
being radicalized okay do you need any
evidence that they're afraid not of
radicalization but just any dissenting
point of view okay look at the results
I'm going to do this when you're done
look at the results of YouTube's latest
crackdown on independent creators okay
they've directed traffic overwhelmingly
away from non-traditional outlets like
people here by the way do you guys
realize we couldn't get the venue
because I was last-minute
this times three and a half is how many
of you showed up for this show
and and I really don't say that to brag
I am so humbled like I had a bucket
right off stage because it's about to
throw up before I come I have horrible
stage fright and the second I saw the
line going around campus I'm like well
there's a good chance someone could
shoot me but this is really inspiring to
see this wouldn't this shouldn't happen
it shouldn't exist and that's why
YouTube and everyone in big tech there's
throttling independent creators and
they're redirecting them back toward
traditional cable TV and networks and
yeah listen our Channel was one of the
hardest hit absolutely
and I'm about taste me but I want you to
follow me okay we were the first
conservative channel talking also about
how many of you showed up it really does
mean a lot to me now I'm not gonna cry
I'm not going to do that because I know
you know sometimes that happens but we
were the first conservative channel
platform to ever survive an attack like
Vox that was leveled against us and when
I say we I mean all of you okay I mean
you didn't sit idly by on the sidelines
you'd see other people
I didn't even have to mention chairs
yeah you guys seriously though you guys
didn't you guys didn't sit on the
sidelines you'd seen other people who
have been deep lat formed before us and
you decided to make a stand and you made
it into a national conversation a
national controversy we wouldn't have
made it without you guys and I really do
thank you from the bottom layer I really
appreciate
[Music]
so we've tried to unveil YouTube's
blacklisting tactics right against
conservative channels and the search
results as you've seen just recently we
exposed YouTube this I don't know if you
watched it the suspicious black listing
of Tulsi gabbard's channel exclusively
in the United States who here followed
that yeah by the way if you search Tulsi
gabbard's channel now the first two
videos that show up are from her Channel
and the third result is her channel
directly and here's the thing I don't
think anyone here wants to see Gabbar to
be President but that's what I
appreciate and love about you guys as I
genuinely do see all of us defending
people with whom we disagree because we
understand that free speech is absolute
and it is for all regardless of how many
[ __ ] say you can't yell fire in a
theater
yeah you know you thought all the time
the resistance right resist Trump
everywhere from brie Larson and Captain
Marvel to Dark Crystal which was real
bummer cuz reporter bladder and iron
nerds we're watching the Dark Crystal
these lesbian puppets can I get it it's
an easy crossover but the points they
talk about resistance generations you
guys are the true resistance you're
resisting big tech the most powerful
companies that by the way have ever
existed I think it would be tough to
argue that there's ever been a more
powerful company in the history of the
world as it relates to the delivery of
information than Google and YouTube and
then right down that list you have Apple
you have Facebook you have Amazon you
have Twitter somewhere on there though I
don't necessarily know where they are on
that list because Jack Dorsey I don't
know what's happening with him he took
some mescaline or something so you guys
are the true resistance and that's
that's a message that needs to be driven
home and that's something that we try to
talk about in our platform even though
I'm not Generation Z all of us have
talked about this when we sit around in
our pitch meetings in the morning we go
oh my god it's just incredible this
didn't exist you know I've been on
YouTube since 2009 I wish I could be an
overnight success that's not what
happened it was a really really slow
slog uphill and then all of a sudden
it's just like the curtains parted and
you guys were all here so what does this
mean Milford for 2020 well first off for
people watching this dream I think I
should what do I look into this I look
into a camera I hit the notification
bell if you're subscribed on YouTube
because subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot and just bookmark the page we have a
news page every single day at 8:00 p.m.
Eastern yes you have a better sense of
time that is correct even though you're
always late but that's just the quarter
of you that is just the quarter
he's all smoking against me you're also
a quarter bad tipper I don't know it's
very unpredictable
oh we just have Prime Minister Trudeau
in blackface some gentle ribbing oh my
producer ashamed of yourself and of
course people who are out there to hear
you do join Mudd Club a lot of comms
last month club odd but you get $20 off
if you use the crowd a spectacular coat
so what does this mean for 2020 well let
me tell you the stakes for 2020 again I
don't want to speak for the opposition
and this is something we've always tried
to do when we watched leftist shows they
would just say something and we where'd
you get that from and they would just
say well that's absolutely right but
well on won't you show me and there are
never any sources there was a
Conservatives going to reach in your
vagina and tell you what you can and
can't do but I've never heard that go to
church like I know a lot of
conservatives they have a source know so
we always try and provide sources
they're always available we always have
a little lower third so in this case how
Drac how severe are the twenty twenty
stakes
I want the voice of political opposition
with whom I disagree I want them to
speak for themselves this is what you
could be facing Generation Z in 2020 you
know the UN just released a study that
said we're going to be okay if the vast
majority of the world goes vegetarian
immediately some of it is with white
bulbs some of it is on straws some of it
dang is on cheeseburgers right
ecologists churches charity should they
lose their tax-exempt status if they
oppose same-sex marriage yes hailing New
York Democratic Governor Andrew Cuomo
for passing a historic bill legalizing
abortion until birth the infant would be
delivered the infant would be kept
comfortable the infant would be
resuscitated if that's what the mother
and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mother just because a
woman or let's also not forget someone
in the trans community
this poor doesn't mean they shouldn't
have the right to exercise that right to
choose hell yes we're gonna take your
ar-15 you're
if it makes you feel any better he fell
off his skateboard okay self-inflicted
harm you either shouting at the street
like you know they can't hear you right
so let's let's let's recap that real
quick bata wants to go to your house and
take compensate your guns and jail you
even if you refuse every single
candidate except for Tulsi Gabbard wants
abortions all the way up until birth but
she's a radical right-wing extremist
because she wants the cutoff to be seven
months the Democrats have voiced support
for the Equality Act which would mean
that female transgenders could compete
in any woman's division in any sport
they want join women's groups churches
and force beauticians to wax their balls
men have periods too and they know that
Ruth Bader Ginsburg is just one choking
on a Werther's original away from the
Supreme Court being changed forever
[Music]
they are petrified of Generation Z they
are petrified of you and then I do have
to get going we're gonna have a quick
real I'm gonna come back for a Q&A I
have to go see the overflow room but
here's I know often people just it's
really easy to come out and just [ __ ]
right I don't think we been bitching
I've been talking about how great this
is for Generation Z but that doesn't
mean that there aren't some steps you
need to take and sometimes people ask me
well how do we fight back against this
because as you mentioned these are huge
companies big tech these are huge
companies the media entertainment
industrial complex here it's really
pretty simple okay let's just let's be
consistent we remain entirely consistent
and campaign against any and all culture
of censorship
I want Generation Z I want everyone out
there to hear the young turks and to
hear Trevor Noah
and to hear Samantha bee speak for
themselves every single week so that we
can be here and rebutted I want to hear
bado
everyone I want to hear the Democrats
cheering gun confiscation I want them
out they're banning Halloween candy I
want I want us to be able to cover
fathers you could potentially lose
custody of their children because they
didn't opt to castrate them chemically
effectively what is it that we do we
can't change what is going on in the
world some of these crazy stories but
what we can do is rather than the left
in attempting to silence voices of
dissent we make sure that their voices
are amplified I want to make sure that
every single far-left candidate and
channel and I hope that you join me
supports the right of all of them to be
on these platforms to get the same level
playing field with suggested feeds with
trending videos that's all we've ever
asked for people don't really understand
our case against YouTube is not about
censorship
it's about dishonest business practices
and not applying the law equally I think
we all need to demand from every single
major company who can determine
elections when you demand what the
guidelines are that we know them and
that there's some system of transparency
so that we know that they are applying
these laws equally I want everyone here
to be as public and as vocal as possible
because here's the deal the left they
want to silence us they want to silence
you they want to ban people right right
now they're talking about banning
political ads on Twitter has anyone ever
thought does that mean they're banning
all media acts
well what kind of invaders do you think
that is for the left Donald Trump can't
run an ad
nor can Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth
Warren but ABC NBC CBS CNN they can all
run ads do you see what's happening
there it's so subversive what they want
is these conversations to happen behind
closed doors and to silence people they
disagree with we shouldn't be doing that
we should demand that their voices be
heard on the exact same platform with
the exact same amplitude as we do and
instead of behind closed doors we should
make it a very public dogfight in
execution ideologically in the streets
so that everyone can witness which
ideology is correct I hope you enjoyed
this clip if you don't these are the
ABCs of me baby you can just click Next
video and put it in double-speed of
course search doesn't necessarily work
subscriptions notifications don't
necessarily work just bookmark this page
chicken we do a new video every single
day except for Sunday and if you don't
want this content to disappear join one
club at Ladder with credit comm slash
bug Club it's only $69 if your student
Feder interactive military and if you
don't you know listen I I don't want to
say that you're hell bound but it that
doesn't look good for you